[Música]
hola muy buenas tardes muy buenas noches
de acuerdo a donde se encuentren y
bienvenidos a este programa especial de
france 24 porque hoy no solo culmina el
año 2020 sino que también asistimos al
capítulo final del break sit y es que
finaliza oficialmente el periodo de
transición que duró 11 meses que se
había fijado para determinar la relación
comercial entre londres y bruselas se
trata de un proceso que comenzó hace ya
casi cuatro años cuando en 2016 reino
unido- celebró un referendo en el que el
52% de los electores votaron a favor de
abandonar la unión europea y aquel día
finalmente llegó el 31 de enero de 2020
el país se convirtió en el primero en
abandonar este bloque tras casi 50 años
de relaciones y comenzó entonces un
periodo de transición para acordar los
términos de las relaciones comerciales
en la era post precise el consenso entre
londres y bruselas llegó el pasado 24 de
diciembre y esta manera se evitó un
divorcio abrupto sin acuerdos en su
primer mensaje de año nuevo el primer
ministro británico boris johnson
manifestó su confianza en que el año
al país esto decía
este es un momento increíble para este
país tenemos nuestra libertad en
nuestras manos y depende de nosotros
aprovecharla al máximo y creo que será
el instinto abrumador de la gente de
este país al unirse como un reino unido
inglaterra escocia gales e irlanda del
norte trabajando juntos para expresar
nuestros valores en todo el mundo
expresó el líder haremos tanto el g7
como la cumbre sobre el cambio climático
con 26 en glasgow y una gran bretaña
global y abierta generosa que mira hacia
afuera internacionalista y de libre
comercio
hasta 2021 es el año en que podemos
hacerlo y creo que 2021 es sobre todo el
año en el que finalmente haremos esas
cosas cotidianas que ahora parecen
perdidas en el pasado post el post y por
supuesto el proceso para llegar a este
divorcio fue largo y muy arduo en el
camino incluso varios funcionarios
británicos de alto rango tuvieron que
dejar sus cargos en medio de las
tensiones que generó esta ruptura
conozcamos en el siguiente informe y la
cronología
y cómo hemos llegado hasta aquí
me explico
alguien más
[Música]
una imagen histórica
el 22 de enero de 1972 el primer
ministro británico edward hit firma el
ingreso de reino unido a la comunidad
económica europea
aunque londres ya había intentado
ingresar a la comunidad en dos
oportunidades bloqueadas por el
presidente francés charles de gaulle el
euroescepticismo estuvo presente desde
el inicio en 1974 el partido laborista
prometió que si ganaba las elecciones la
gente podría decidir en las urnas si
quería seguir perteneciendo al mercado
común el 5 de junio de 1935 el gobierno
del primer ministro harold wilson llevó
a cabo el referendo pese a que la
decisión en esa oportunidad fue
permanecer los euroescépticos no se
detendrían en su aspiración por romper
con europa el más popular de ellos nagel
farage un político que se abrió camino
como líder del ala más dura de los
partidarios de abandonar europa me gusta
la cultura europea pero dio la bandera
odio el himno odio las instituciones en
2015 la historia se repetiría pero en
esta oportunidad fue el gobierno
conservador de david cameron el que
embasó su campaña electoral en la
promesa de un nuevo referendo anunciando
que haría campaña porque el reino unido-
permaneciera en una unión europea
reformada una vez reelegido el primer
ministro cumple
y el 23 de junio de 2016 el pueblo
británico después de una turbulenta
campaña marcada por la propaganda y los
pequeños elige salir de la unión europea
al día siguiente cameron duramente
criticado dimitir pero hay unos en
yibutí no creo que sea correcto que yo
intenté ser el capitán que dirija a
nuestro país hacia su próximo destino
para maniobrar el barco a la deriva los
conservadores la eligen a ella
theresa me llega al número 10 de downing
street con una misión difícil por
delante el 28 de marzo de 2017 la
primera ministra firma la carta en la
que invoca el artículo 50 del tratado de
lisboa y en la que informa a las
autoridades de bruselas de la intención
de su país de abandonar la unión europea
a partir de ese momento londres y
bruselas se fijaron un plazo de dos años
para acordar los términos de la salida
del reino unido- de la unión europea
buscando consolidar al partido
conservador may anuncia elecciones
anticipadas para junio de 2017 pero la
jugada no le sale bien de los 330
escaños que tenían los conservadores
pierden 12 y ahora deberán buscar
alianzas para formar un gobierno sus
nuevos socios serían los unionistas de
irlanda del norte durante 2017 y
principios de 2018 las conversaciones
con la unión europea continúan pese a
que en todo momento may se muestra
optimista su propio partido empieza a
darle la espalda casi una veintena de
sus altos funcionarios renuncian y su
popularidad se viene a pique el 14 de
noviembre de 2018 londres y bruselas
alcanzan un principio de acuerdo sobre
el break city
25 del mismo mes los 27 miembros del
bloque comunitario lo aprueban entre el
15 de enero y el 29 de marzo de 2019 las
propuestas de acuerdo de mey sufren
cuatro contundentes derrotas en la
cámara de los comunes
y si es a la derecha 242 no está la
izquierda 391
ese día se cumple la fecha límite que se
habían fijado las partes para llegar a
un acuerdo y tras los traspiés sufridos
la premier pide prórrogas a bruselas en
dos ocasiones la unión europea decide
dárselas basados en el artículo 50 es
hasta el 31 de octubre
perfecto sin embargo acorralada dentro
de su propio partido el 24 de mayo may
dimitir lo hago sin mala voluntad con
una gratitud enorme y duradera por haber
tenido la oportunidad de servir al país
que amo
una de las imágenes más representativas
de este proceso los parlamentarios
británicos probé excitan la espalda al
himno de la unión europea
el elegido por los conservadores para
completar el break sit es el ex alcalde
de londres y ex ministro de exteriores-
boris johnson saldremos de la unión
europea el 31 de octubre sin peros el 29
de agosto johnson toma una de las
decisiones más polémicas del proceso y
suspende el parlamento para que la
oposición no vete un break sin acuerdo
el cierre desata una situación caótica
en el país con llamados de la oposición
a los británicos a tomar las calles el
17 de octubre johnson y bruselas llegan
a un acuerdo sobre uno de los puntos más
polémicos el manejo de la frontera entre
irlanda del norte y parte del reino
unido e irlanda miembro de la unión
europea
juntos hemos logrado un resultado justo
y razonable
nuevamente la palabra final la tiene el
parlamento del reino unido que el 19 de
octubre se reúne en una sesión
extraordinaria por primera vez en muchos
años un sábado los parlamentarios
británicos votan para retrasar la
decisión argumentando que necesitan más
tiempo para estudiar su contenido
johnson pide una tercera prórroga
bruselas con fecha límite del 31 de
enero de 2020 tras cuatro intentos
johnson logra finalmente el apoyo del
parlamento a la convocatoria de
elecciones anticipadas en diciembre el
premier logra la mayoría más aplastante
del partido conservador desde la era
thatcher con 364 escaños y con este
mandato y esta mayoría finalmente
podremos hacer que
en enero de 2020 tanto el parlamento
británico como el europeo dan luz verde
al plan de johnson
entonces el 31 de enero llega la tan
esperada fecha para los partidarios del
break city
[Aplausos]
la pandemia frena en gran parte las
conversaciones y nuevamente en diciembre
del 2020 se reactivan con los esfuerzos
para llegar a un acuerdo cuando parece
que el tiempo se agota el día de navidad
las dos partes anuncian que han llegado
a un acuerdo comercial ambas partes
enfrentan retos inmensos para mantener
la armonía en el nuevo escenario en
especial boris johnson que ha
reivindicado para los partidarios del
president de la soberanía británica
deberá demostrar que la salida de la
casa común europea después de casi medio
siglo de compartirla no acarreará una
desmejora de las condiciones de sus
ciudadanos
y en france 24 por supuesto tenemos
información desde el lugar mismo de los
hechos y por eso vamos ahora a londres
la capital británica para ampliar la
información con nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido luisa muy buenas noches por
allí estamos viendo los primeros minutos
del presi de fini tivo oficial no hay
que coincide precisamente con la fecha
de celebraciones de año nuevo contános
luisa cómo se están viviendo estos
momentos en la capital británica
buenas noches santiago y a todos los
televidentes es el momento definitivo
cuatro años y medio después de que
iniciara este divorcio de la relación
entre el reino unido y la unión europea-
de más de 50 años finalmente será este
día acaba formalmente hace 9 minutos de
terminar el periodo de transición en el
que como ya lo hemos visto las partes
tenían que ponerse de acuerdo como a
partir del primero de enero de 2021 es
decir dentro de menos de una hora
iniciará el nuevo año aquí en el reino
unido- la unión europea y el reino
unido- empezarán una nueva relación un
nuevo capítulo que tiene gran parte un
acuerdo comercial se espera que sea una
relación menos conflictiva son momentos
de mucha tranquilidad santiago debo
decirles que la noticia del break city
como digo cuatro años y medio de drama
de nostalgia han pasado prácticamente a
un segundo plano la gente está muy
triste hay una sensación de soledad de
emotividad por este año
muy complejo aquí en el reino unido hoy
tuvimos más de 53.000 nuevos casos de
contagio de coronavirus y les han pedido
los integrantes del gobierno de la
alcaldía de londres a las personas que
se queden en sus casas que no salgan a
ver las luces artificiales que eviten
las fiestas del nuevo año porque la
situación es muy compleja y como les
digo la noticia del president ha pasado
a un segundo plano por esto por esta
sensación es un año muy complejo 11
minutos precisamente han pasado luisa
desde el inicio del divorcio oficial
esto lo estábamos viendo recién en un
conteo en imágenes en directos que
llegan desde europa
louis a boris johnson hoy en su discurso
dedicado al fin de año dijo entre otras
cosas que vendría más libertad para el
país algo más para destacar de sus
palabras
sí claro es un discurso con una
narrativa de triunfador boris johnson ha
enfatizado desde hace una semana cuando
se firmó cuando se terminó de negociar
el acuerdo con la unión europea en que
el reino unido- obtuvo lo que quería en
esta negociación que fue frenética de 10
meses inició en marzo y terminó el 24 de
diciembre como regalo de navidad dicen
muchos así que boris johnson ha dicho
hoy primero ha dado una luz de esperanza
con las vacunas de oxford y astrazéneca
que esta jornada histórica de vacunación
iniciará el próximo lunes 4 de enero
aquí en el reino unido ha dicho boris
johnson además haciendo referencia al
break sida al día que estamos viviendo
hoy que será la oportunidad para que el
reino unido se convierta en esa
estrategia en ese plan que tiene de
global bridge que le permitirá entonces
hacer acuerdos de libre comercio con
otros países especialmente con eeuu que
es una de sus prioridades y también está
súper claro y marcado toda esta
narrativa la ambición del primer
ministro
que el reino unido se convierta en una
superpotencia ha hecho mucho énfasis en
la importancia de la inversión en la
ciencia también haciendo un guiño y una
clarísima referencia a irlanda del norte
que ha sido parte fundamental y una de
las más complejas en las negociaciones
del bec sheet y también a escocia que
tiene muchas posibilidades de
independizarse del reino unido ha dicho
que juntos como reino unido van a
expresar sus valores a lo largo y ancho
del mundo así que boris johnson ha
tratado de ser optimista en este mes en
este mensaje de fin de año a darle al
país un poco más de tranquilidad ha
dicho que vienen días y semanas muy
difíciles porque el invierno hasta ahora
está comenzando y como les digo los
casos de el coronavirus se están
aumentando en el país más del 70% de
inglaterra están las tres destrucciones
de confinamiento más complejas no se
puede socializar se sólo se puede salir
a la calle a lo básico hacer las compras
pero no más así que el primer ministro
ha tratado de
mismo pero también de decir que una vez
se supere toda esta situación de la
pandemia con la jornada histórica de
vacunación que ya inició en los
principios de diciembre con la vacuna de
facer entonces el reino unido podrá dar
un paso adelante y convertirse en esa
superpotencia económica ha dicho además
que se mantendrá muy cercano a europa
por supuesto pero ahora bien en
relaciones el otro tono relaciones
distintas ya no habrá una integración
política sino que será una integración
en esencia económica y eso lo ha dejado
muy claro boris johnson pero santiago
también me parece importante decirles a
nuestros televidentes que el capítulo
del break sheet se creía que se acaba
pero todavía hay muchas cosas por
negociar todavía hay muchos puntos
importantes que quedan sobre la mesa y
deben empezar a negociarse en los
próximos meses como qué va a pasar con
los con los sistemas financieros el
reino unido
básicamente especialmente en londres por
el distrito financiero la city que es
pues se pasan la mayor parte de las
transacciones del mundo
entonces que empezará a negociarse
precisamente erizada sobre esos puntos
que mencionabas al final de tu alocución
vamos a estar hablando dentro de unos
minutos contigo y también con invitados
expertos para este programa especial un
break si tu hija que como bien decía se
dan unas circunstancias muy particulares
no el último año de este 2020 en plena
pandemia de coronavirus con
restricciones a lo largo de todo el
mundo y sobre todo en reino unido- luís
hablemos contigo en cualquier momento a
lo largo de este programa especial
porque como decíamos el 24 de diciembre
de londres y bruselas alcanzaron un
acuerdo comercial para la relación post
preside el pacto abarca no sólo el
comercio de productos sino también temas
como por ejemplo la circulación de
personas las competencias o también el
transporte y en este informe vamos a
repasar las claves del pacto que pone
fin a 47 años de membresía británica en
el bloque europeo
es el fin a una relación de 47 años
reino unido y la unión europea-
definieron un histórico acuerdo
comercial y de cooperación post pre
decide el pacto prevé el libre
intercambio de bienes y servicios sin
aranceles ni cuotas aunque con más
restricciones que en la transición una
salida airosa para el reino unido- que
se arriesgaba a enfrentar tarifas o
luego de tres décadas en el mercado
único el acuerdo también modifica las
reglas en un área clave la pesca con
esta normativa la unión europea acepta
un recorte del 25 por ciento de las
cuotas en aguas británicas durante 5
años y medio estará garantizado el
acceso recíproco a las aguas pero tras
ese periodo las condiciones se definirán
en negociaciones anuales frutas time
shifting semtur y por primera vez desde
1973 seremos un estado costero
independiente con control total de
nuestras aguas con la participación del
reino unido- de la pesca aumentando
sustancialmente de aproximadamente la
mitad actual a más de cerca de dos
tercios en cinco años y medio
en la fiesta
el texto contempla que londres y
bruselas mantengan un campo de juego
nivelado con los mismos estándares de
competencia y protección al medio
ambiente
desde el primero de enero de 2021
existirán controles aduaneros en las
fronteras y los ciudadanos no podrán
circular libremente instalarse y
trabajar o estudiar para estancias
superiores a 90 días se deberán
solicitar los visados correspondientes
también se acabarán reconocimientos
mutuos de las calificaciones
profesionales
sé que este es un día difícil para
algunos y a nuestros amigos en
reinounido quiero decirles despedirse es
un dolor tan dulce harting es sachs
sweet
una despedida que tampoco será
definitiva a la cooperación esperada
entre las partes se agrega que el
acuerdo incluye periodos de transición y
cláusulas de revisión lo que vaticina
nuevas negociaciones en el futuro
y si bien en la unión europea' y reino
unido- alcanzaron un acuerdo que define
sus relaciones comerciales en la era
post break sit todavía no hay pactos
claros sobre determinados temas como por
ejemplo la operación de los servicios
financieros ingleses en el resto de
europa tampoco queda claro al momento
como los británicos van a reemplazar los
sistemas de seguridad que brinda la
unión europea para rastrear en vivo
alertas terroristas ni hubo tampoco un
acuerdo final para poder garantizar el
flujo de datos de europeos que utilizan
las organizaciones británicas y
viceversa no obstante se llegó a un
acuerdo respecto de uno de los puntos
más conflictivos y que más le preocupaba
a españa estamos hablando de la frontera
con gibraltar un territorio británico
localizado en el sur de la península
ibérica y por donde pasan a diario
15.000 personas pero horas antes
precisamente de la entrada en vigor del
break city oficial los países alcanzaron
un principio de acuerdo que garantiza la
movilidad en la frontera y también la
libre circulación de ciudadanos ya mismo
volvemos a londres la capital británica
para seguir conociendo cómo se vive
y esta jornada clave e histórica louis
ha pulido nuevamente buenas noches a
último momento como decíamos reino unido
llegó a un acuerdo con españa por la
frontera con gibraltar uno de los puntos
más conflictivos no de estas
negociaciones contanos cuál era
puntualmente ese conflicto
santiago como lo dices y como lo hace
remarcado durante toda la jornada por
supuesto las negociaciones del preside
han sido conflictivas desde todo punto
de vista y además son únicas porque el
reino unido es el primer país que deja
esta comunidad así que todo lo que pase
de aquí en adelante pues habrá que
observarlo con mucha minucia porque como
dice es el acuerdo está firmado pero hay
muchos puntos todavía por negociar como
de último minuto también fue como dices
el acuerdo entre el gobierno español y
el gobierno británico para que gibraltar
es una territorio británico ultramar no
se convierta en una frontera exterior de
la unión europea eso que significa que
gibraltar se convertirá entrará en la
zona schengen que hace parte de los 26
países de la unión europea de los 27
países así que entonces se unirá a esta
comunidad quienes viajen desde españa a
gibraltar no necesitarán pasaporte pero
si los británicos que vayan desde este
país hacia esa zona entonces tendrán que
su documento de identidad para poder
ingresar al país se ha hablado de que se
revisara este principio de acuerdo cada
cuatro años es así que es un punto bien
importante santiago pero también por
ejemplo en el caso del nuevo sistema
migratorio que el reino unido- estrenará
a partir de mañana para los ciudadanos
europeos porque se acaba la libre
circulación de ciudadanos es decir
quienes quieran venir a trabajar oa
estudiar ciudadanos europeos por
supuesto a este país deben someterse a
un sistema migratorio de puntos que
demostrar por ejemplo que hablan inglés
que tienen calificaciones para poder
apostar a un trabajo aquí y hasta que
tienen un contrato laboral en el caso de
los británicos que viven o quieren hacer
lo mismo trabajar o vivir en otros
países europeos tendrán entonces que
someterse a las reglas migratorias que
imponga cada país porque santiago por
supuesto sobre todo cuando se pueda
viajar en las épocas del invierno muchos
británicos quieren ir a países del
mediterráneo como italia grecia a españa
seguramente limitaciones de movilidad
louis ya que afectan quizás más que nada
a los sectores más jóvenes
ha sido en verdad
por supuesto recuerdo en el 2016 cuando
se votó el referendo para salir de la
unión europea la población más golpeada
eran los jóvenes porque veían en esto en
la libre circulación de ciudadanos una
oportunidad para aprender idiomas para
transformar su vida así que fue un golpe
para ellos y también porque el reino
unido- saliendo de la unión europea se
retira del programa erasmus para hacer
intercambio universitario entre ciudad
entre universidades europeas pero este
país el reino unido lanzó un programa
especial similar en el que se puede
hacer esto pero con todas las
universidades del mundo así que los
jóvenes han sentido como ese impacto
también por las vacaciones es bien
interesante santiago como en estos días
en que estamos que la noticia más
importante que ocupan nuestras vidas es
la situación con con el coronavirus pero
cuando se pueda volver a viajar entonces
el impacto para la mayoría de la
población se notará por supuesto porque
porque todo se transformará para los
viajeros británicos y los europeos entre
aeropuerto
por el solo hecho de dónde van a hacer
fila en los aeropuertos británicos los
europeos
entran como ciudadanos británicos y el
viceversa en los aeropuertos europeos
ahora no si un europeo viene este país
tiene que hacer fila como las dos otras
nacionalidades los viajeros de otras
nacionalidades también sea el gobierno
ha pedido a los viajeros que vayan a
europa que entonces su sistema de
telefonía puede tener incluso un cobro
adicional porque el roaming puede
empezar a ser cobrado eso es algo que no
pasa en este momento y también les han
dicho el gobierno a los viajeros que lo
mejor es que contraten un seguro de
viajes así que todos estos impactos se
van a ir sintiendo poco a poco porque la
noticia de coronavirus es tan compleja
que la gente no puede salir y parte de
lo que va a empezar a notarse por
supuesto es con las vacaciones con los
alimentos habrá entonces incremento de
los precios porque más del 50% de los
alimentos frescos que se consume en el
reino unido- provienen de países como
italia como españa
como grecia así que habrá que ver qué va
a suceder finalmente gracias a luisa
pulido por este completísimo reporte
pero volvemos contigo en cualquier
momento para seguir analizando lo que
sucede allí en la capital británica y
ahora nos acompaña daniela hablando un
periodista de france 24 experta en
mantén temas económicos porque como
decíamos 11 meses demoraron las
negociaciones para llegar a un acuerdo
comercial y económico post break sit y
negociaciones que incluyeron cambios
implicancias consecuencias verdades
daniela cómo es la relación comercial
hoy del reino unido y la unión europea
hola santiago pues mire estamos hablando
de dos bloques de peso bastante
diferente y por eso justamente las
negociaciones no fueron nada fáciles por
un lado la población de la unión europea
es de casi 450 millones de habitantes y
la del reino unido es seis veces menor
casi 67 millones pero si hablamos de
comercio bilateral ambos bloques tienen
un mercado común de más de un billón de
dólares al año en la unión europea es el
principal socio comercial de gran
bretaña santiago porque representa
y la mitad de su comercio total aquí
estamos sumando importaciones y
exportaciones
en cambio la dependencia de la unión
europea sobre el reino unido es mucho
menor y representa apenas el 13 por
ciento de su comercio lo que más vende
line unido son servicios sobre todo
financieros y del lado de la unión
europea lo que más le vende al reino
unido son coches y productos
farmacéuticos los llamativos en este
asunto santiago es que pues uno de los
puntos más controversiales fue por
supuesto el de la pesca pero su peso en
la economía británica es muy poco es de
apenas el 0,1 por ciento del pib la
verdad que sí llamativo este último
punto porque fue uno de los principales
obstáculos en las negociaciones tenían
ahí cuáles son los principales aspectos
del acuerdo comercial que finalmente
firmaron el pasado 24 de diciembre
verdad claro mire a grandes rasgos el
acuerdo consiste en que no habrá
aranceles ni cuotas en el comercio
bilateral que era lo que más les
preocupaba a los comerciantes pero sí
habrá más papeleo porque el reino unido
ya no será parte de la unión aduanera ni
del mercado común del bloque comunitario
lo que implica más controles fronterizos
así que lo que se espera de ahora en
adelante de santiago son grandes filas
quienes intenten cruzar la frontera
tendrán que llenar formularios y
declaraciones de aduanas y también habrá
más controles y más estrictos sobre los
productos agrícolas pero uno de los
cambios más notables y también como lo
mencionaba luisa sin duda alguna será el
tránsito de personas que ya no será
libre desde ese primero de enero y eso
significa que quienes quieran permanecer
en estos territorios por periodos
superiores a tres meses van a tener que
solicitar visa y una pregunta clave que
surge por supuesto llegando al final ya
como despidieron el año de los mercados
en europa en medio del break sheet mire
las únicas bolsas que operaron hoy
fueron las de londres parís y madrid el
resto ya estaba en 2021 y todas se
cerraron a la baja sobre todo londres
que perdió el 1,45 por ciento todo esto
en medio de la incertidumbre por el
break city esto tuvo bastante que ver
pero también santiago el anuncio que
hizo hoy eeuu sobre la aplicación de más
aranceles a productos europeos
esta interminable guerra comercial por
los subsidios aeronáuticos en el andar
muchisimas gracias por ayudarnos a
comprender un poco mas todas las
cuestiones comerciales y económicas que
rodean a este polémico break city vamos
a saludar ahora a nicolas maurice yo les
docente de relaciones internacionales
con él vamos a continuar analizando esta
jornada clave para reino unido y para el
bloque de la unión europea señor
mauricio en primer lugar muchísimas
gracias por estos minutos por su
presencia en france 24 bueno han pasado
años de negociaciones quien cree usted
que se dio más en este acuerdo hay
alguna parte más beneficiada que la otra
buenas noches muchísimas gracias a
ustedes por invitarme que es una
pregunta difícil es una pregunta difícil
de responder porque los el interés de la
unión europea y el interés británico es
doble no en los dos en los dos casos
tenemos una conjugación de intereses el
primero que es económico que es el que
creo que se salvó más o menos en ambos
de ambos lados y creo que en este
sentido europa se dio de pronto menos
que lo que pudo es que debió ser el gran
bretaña porque pues lo que como dijeron
ustedes lo que más vende de gran bretaña
son servicios financieros y en términos
financieros en términos de la fuerza y
de los de los traders como se llaman en
gran bretaña pierde el acceso al mercado
único y esto sí es una digamos una
victoria entre comillas una muestra
fuerte de la vez de la decisión y de la
voluntad de la unión europea sin embargo
hay una una ganancia y es que pues el
acceso al mercado único en términos de
exportaciones desde productos de bienes
este si se mantiene
y bueno en ese orden de ideas creo que
yo pensar pensaría que los dos se dieron
y que por qué que finalmente es un
empate que los dos pueden estar
contentos
europa porque perdió el entendido de los
aranceles porque pues finalmente se dio
y no habrá aranceles para los productos
británicos pero tampoco habrá para los
productos europeos que van a agravar
cadencias en un sentido no pierde tanto
pero sobre todo porque se preserva el
derecho de la unión en tomar sanciones y
subir los aranceles si en londres y
digamos s
[Música]
digamos se inicia una una una política
de competencia desleal o no cumplen los
acuerdos y en esa orden de ideas gran
bretaña sigue sometida de alguna manera
a las reglas del comercio las reglas
sociales a las reglas fiscales de la
unión por lo tanto la independencia
digamos en políticas económicas de gran
bretaña es cuestionable no obviamente no
es nula pero de alguna manera es su
margen de maniobra es mucho menor que lo
que se planteaba lo que quería boris
johnson agregue a eso el tema de que
irlanda se mantiene en la unión europea'
del término sede de hecho yo creo que en
realidad es
el éxito es más de la de la unión por el
lado político sin embargo ambas ambos
ambas partes han jugado sus cartas
bastante bien y creo que de ambos lados
de la tela del chalet están están
reivindicando un poco la victoria en los
acuerdos pero yo creería personalmente
que es un acuerdo es un acuerdo
equilibrado agrava usted recién acerca
del comercio de bienes pero hay
incertidumbre todavía de respecto de los
servicios no que sí representa en un
sector de gran peso para la economía
británica tiene usted información
respecto de qué va a pasar con el sector
de los servicios pues por eso le decía
que gran bretaña para mí perdió un poco
más que la unión porque pues su mayor su
mayor nivel de negocio digamos su mayor
cifra de negocios se hace en los
servicios y en particular los servicios
bursátiles financia y financieros por la
por la economía particular que margaret
thatcher impulsó en gran bretaña al
final de los 90 años
perdón al final 280 en el inicio de los
lo que va a pasar en este instante pues
es en luxemburgo parís y fráncfort se
están frotando las manos esperando ganar
y esperando beneficiarse digamos de esta
falta de acceso de las empresas
británicas porque ya no tienen el
pasaporte financiero ya no pueden
acceder al mercado sin instalarse en la
unión europea sin instalar sus oficinas
en la unión europea y obviamente esto
pues es una eso es un costo es un costo
adicional para ellos y naturalmente
también él generará un desplazamiento de
activos desde gran bretaña hacia el
continente y de hecho ya este este
desplazamiento de activos y el peso
última que se destaca que llama la
atención lo hablamos precisamente
recientemente con daniel hablando
nuestra periodista experta en temas
económicos porque la pesca es una
actividad que para reino unido
representa tan sólo el 0.1 por ciento de
su producto interno bruto y sin embargo
fue uno de los principales obstáculos
durante estas negociaciones porque cree
usted que fue tan espinoso este tema en
particular
porque bueno como le decía antes el tema
del pre existe es un tema que tiene dos
singles fundamentales una es la
económica y en términos económicos
digamos que el éxito no tiene sentido no
tiene sentido por donde lo miren por
donde se mire no tiene sentido el éxito
por donde tiene sentido más bien es en
el tema económico y el tema perdón
político y en términos políticos tenemos
nos enfrentamos a una irracionalidad la
política pues ha demostrado
históricamente que no es racional y en
este caso menos y el tema de los
pescadores tanto en francia como en gran
bretaña es un gremio es un gremio activo
es un gremio digamos muy bastante
conservador pero también es bastante
importante para digamos los temas
electorales y los temas de votaciones
entonces
es experto es una hipertrofia política
en el tema económico no tan importante
pero en temas nacionalismos de
nacionalismo era simbólico porque las
aguas territoriales son un tema que
evidentemente en temas de política de
administración de política nacional es
un tema bastante bastante digamos
espinoso me propongo seguir analizando
algunas de las consecuencias no y
también de los cambios que se vienen
ahora a partir de este divorcio que ya
se hizo oficial y formal y uno de los
puntos más polémicos tiene que ver con
el fin de la libertad de movimiento
pasados los 90 días por ejemplo en un
país los ciudadanos van a tener que
solicitar visas estos límites a la
circulación afectan de manera particular
a los jóvenes lo dialoga mos con nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis ha pulido
que pierden en particular las nuevas
generaciones con el break sheet
esa es una pregunta interesante pues en
realidad no pierden mucho hay que ser
sinceros eso es más como es más
simbólico que otra cosa porque hay que
cambiar de fila cuando uno llega al
aeropuerto no es digamos que tampoco es
tan grave
no sé si todavía se tendrá acceso a la
migración electrónica como se tenía
acceso hasta ahora para como lo llaman
allá pero es más en términos de
intercambios estudiantiles porque en
términos de turismo de vacaciones sí sí
van a pasar menos de tres meses lo que
normalmente no alcanza a durar una
vacación podrán viajar igual que antes
desde en esta orden de ideas pues
simplemente tienen que cambiar de fila y
de pronto pues se tendrán algunos de
nostalgia de que antes pasaban por el
lado donde están los británicos y ya no
pero tampoco no no creo que esto se
realmente sea relevante salvo de pronto
que se van a demorar un poco más al
pasar en términos de intercambios
efectivamente eso sí es más grave porque
era el programa erasmus europeo y
después erasmus mundus también pero el
programa erasmus era un avance enorme
porque creó una ciudadanía europea hay
que reconocerlo en los jóvenes en
particular creo en los jóvenes que
estudiaban y que beneficiaron
evidentemente de este servicio entre
comillas creó una generación europeísta
obviamente usted se podrá mirar por
donde yo creería que si se hiciera una
encuesta se da en cuenta que la juventud
y euroescéptica y la juventud europeísta
se puede diferenciar en parte sobre este
aspecto de la erasmus y en esa orden de
ideas hay 150 mil estudiantes anuales
que no podrán ir a inglaterra porque a
gran bretaña porque las universidades no
estarán en la propuesta en la lista de
establecimientos o de instituciones
propuestas yo creo que eso es una
pérdida una pérdida grave para los
jóvenes europeos de no poder ir a
perfeccionar su inglés a conocer otra
cultura pero es más uno digamos yo creo
que pierde más la juventud inglesa o
británica porque no podrá ella así
beneficiar o enriquecer digamos su
patrimonio cultural su patrimonio
idiomático sus conocimientos también con
muchos más son muchos más socios digamos
ya sea en un caso en un caso se pierden
cuatro socios en el otro se pierde en 27
entonces pues para la juventud
estudiante eso sí que es una pérdida
pero yo no desespero que lleguen a un
acuerdo porque así sea costoso según
boris johnson este acuerdo para gran
bretaña yo no lo dudo de que logren
llegar a un acuerdo a futuro porque la
juventud también importa en las
elecciones
de la juventud y de este descontento que
podría haber entre este sector de la
población cree usted que quizás en un
futuro nuevo con una nueva generación de
dirigentes que hoy son jóvenes puede
haber un regreso de reino unido a la
unión europea
pues naturalmente como decía su colega
que no me acuerdo del nombre va a tocar
demostrado el sistema migratorio
británico es un sistema de no sé si son
el ejemplo del fútbol pero para poder
migrar para trabajar en gran bretaña
cuando uno no es miembro de la comunidad
de o del commonwealth o de hoy o hasta
ahora de la unión europea toca demostrar
una capacidad un beneficio que se puede
aportar la sociedad a la sociedad
británica
de hecho la migración a europa para
ciudadanos latinoamericanos a menudo se
basa en criterios similares a esos es
decir que para muchos europeos que están
estudiando allá en este momento que
están viviendo allá les va a tocar
demostrar
les va a tocar demostrar que tiene algo
que aportar el europeo por ejemplo que
tenía un contrato que sí que se acababa
en diciembre delante este año por
ejemplo pues va a tener mucho más mucha
más dificultad para renovarlo
probablemente pero es así como es y como
es en todas partes salvo que pueda es
algo que sea realmente una sets para su
para su compañía yo me imagino que si va
a generar algo pero también me imagino
repito que las negociaciones entre la
unión europea y el reino unido no han
terminado esta noche el tenemos un
acuerdo marco un acuerdo sobre las bases
los elementos principales del comercio
pero como lo dijo su colega en londres
ahorita quedan un montón de temas por
negociar y yo veo más una relación que
se pasará como en el modelo con suiza es
decir que permanentemente en los
próximos 30 a 30 años a no no lo va a
decir así va a haber haber negociaciones
permanentes sobre todo toda clase de
temas
nicola municio volvemos con ustedes en
cualquier momento vamos nuevamente a
londres la capital británica para seguir
dialogando con nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido luisa bueno ahí ya en este
contexto empiezan a sobrevolar por la
región no vientos
en este sentido contanos cuál es la
situación en irlanda del norte y en
escocia
bueno hablas de dos de los asuntos más
complejos en las negociaciones y que son
al mismo tiempo dos de los asuntos más
difíciles para el futuro políticamente
irlanda del norte- recordemos tiene un
protocolo especial en el acuerdo firmado
entonces recordemos irlanda del norte
había que protegerla porque estaba en
peligro síntesis se ponía una frontera
física entre la república de irlanda que
está dentro de la unión europea e
irlanda del norte que hace el parte del
reino unido- si se ponía una nueva
frontera física entre estas dos zonas
entonces podría crear un nuevo conflicto
y recordemos importante aquí se dio un
conflicto bien bien difícil conocido
como los troubles se firmó el acuerdo de
paz en 1998 y uno de los puntos
importantes en ese acuerdo de paz era
que las fronteras físicas se aburrían
que sucede en el acuerdo entonces ahora
e irlanda del norte queda dentro del
mercado común de la unión europea tiene
un protocolo distinto un tratamiento
diferente habrá una frontera en el mar
pero que evitará tocar ese punto entre
irlanda del norte y la república de
irlanda son una misma isla divididos un
asta en la unión europea y otra está en
el reino unido también hay posibilidades
especialmente de los republicanos que
quieren la unificación de la isla de
irlanda así que ese es un punto que no
hay que perder de vista el otro es
escocia escocia voto mayoritariamente en
el referendo de 2016 por permanecer en
la unión europea el partido nacional
escocés que lidera nicola sturgeon la
primera ministra de ese país ha dicho
que su prioridad será buscar la
independencia del reino unido porque
quieren ser un país independiente y
regresar a la unión europea porque se
consideran más europeos que británicos
hoy
política y jurídicamente esa posibilidad
no existe en el 2015 un referendo en el
que los escoceses dijeron
mayoritariamente que no que prefería
mantenerse dentro del reino unido porque
entonces en ese momento se hizo campaña
para que si de escocia se mantenía
dentro del reino unido- entonces no
habría este break sheet y eso no fue lo
que sucedió entonces el partido nacional
escocés está promoviendo esa
independencia ahora con toda la
situación de la pandemia del coronavirus
y el manejo que le ha dado nicolás
torrent que ha tomado decisiones
independientes a las del resto del reino
unido- esto ha favorecido la imagen de
la posibilidad de la independencia y es
un camino bien complejo que empieza a
abrirse del mayo de 2021 habrá
elecciones regionales en escocia y si al
partido nacional escocés le va tan bien
como en las elecciones de 2019 del
parlamento británico estaremos hablando
de que políticamente a boris johnson le
tocará darle la oportunidad
de un segundo referendo a escocia para
saber si se queda o no dentro de la
unión dentro del reino unido para unirse
posteriormente con una nación
independiente a la unión europea esos
son los planes que tienen en escocia no
sabemos finalmente si va a suceder
santiago todo estamos hablando de un
camino lleno de incertidumbres habrá que
esperar que puede suceder en estas
elecciones pero lo cierto es que con el
manejo que nicolás está ordenado sobre
la pandemia se ha convertido en una
líder que ha demostrado autonomía sobre
westminster sobre el primer ministro con
una imagen un poco más seria que el
primer ministro boris johnson que en
algunos momentos ha dado unos mensajes
ambiguos sobre esta pandemia así que
vamos a ver qué puede esperar el pasar
pero lo cierto es que la independencia
empieza a abrirse camino no toda la
población de escoceses está convencida
de que ese sea el camino pero lo cierto
es que esa es la prioridad del partido
nacional escocés que está en el poder
ahora lo está volviendo a las irlanda no
en este contexto que también describía
si están completamente vacías es más
factible una posibilidad de
reunificación entre las islandesas
pues santiago digamos que esa es una de
las preguntas más complejas
políticamente sobre sobre el futuro no
se sabe finalmente si se podrá dar
están las posibilidades dadas
políticamente tal vez si por supuesto es
una de las aspiraciones de los
republicanos en irlanda del norte no se
sienten parte del reino unido- sienten
que londres es un territorio muy lejano
en el caso del break city que no
interpretó ni escucho sus necesidades
así que es una situación bien compleja
al partido unionista de irlanda del
norte está criticando el acuerdo de
hecho votó ayer en contra de éste por
considerar que rompe el reino unido- así
que es una situación bien compleja lo
que puede pasar en irlanda del norte y
lo cierto es que no se sabe finalmente
que puede pasar
socialista por otro completísimo reporte
volvemos a comunicarnos con nicolás
mauricio docente de relaciones
internacionales señor munición teniendo
en cuenta bueno usted es experto en
relaciones internacionales que se puede
augurar en posibles cambios en materia
de relaciones entre reino unido y
américa latina por ejemplo
porque gracias por esta pregunta
me esperaba el / pues ver la mayoría de
la mayoría de acuerdos digamos
comerciales que se han construido entre
américa latina y europa por ejemplo en
los últimos hay en los últimos años las
últimas décadas han sido construidos con
la unión europea proceso para en primer
lugar el primer cambio notable va a ser
efecto para es que los tratados de libre
comercio existentes ya no existen y que
toca renegociar las de renegociarlos
para el tema digamos que para una para
el tema comercial pues es una
oportunidad para los países
latinoamericanos para negociar acuerdos
de afrontó favorables de pronto también
para negociar otros productos que no
hubieran sido posibles en caso pues
porque la unión europea tiene normas más
estrictas notablemente entre los
fitosanitarios
pienso en el tlc como por ejemplo el
mercosur posiblemente será más será más
fácil negociar un acuerdo con gran
bretaña sola que con la unión europea
entera y en ese sentido será más ágil en
términos por ejemplo de tráfico aéreo
para los turistas latinoamericanos
significa por posiblemente
aunque no tenían nada en parte de
schengen entonces ya de por sí era en
particular el estatus pero posiblemente
generará más dificultad para pasar por
el reino unido- significa también volver
a negociar acuerdos de visas y ese tipo
de cosas porque pues ella
de pronto algunas algunas facilidades se
podrán caer aunque pues como dije antes
como una forma parte de schengen
originalmente disfruto incluso no y en
términos de cooperación pues de por sí
la cooperación en la cooperación
internacional era una es una competencia
compartida en la unión europea entonces
ya los países europeos tienen sus
propias agencias de cooperación además
de las agencias de cooperación de la
comisión europea y del parlamento
europeo
por lo que pues los cambios de pronto
nos no van a ser tan notables para mí
son más oportunidades comerciales de
pronto de comerciar otros productos que
no estaban previstos en los tratados
actuales con europa y probablemente les
digamos ventajas ventajas competitivas
para poder renegociar los los acuerdos
del resto no creo que no creo que el
impacto sea extraordinario salvo
evidentemente que la economía británica
no nos responda y que pues no pueda
hacer un socio comercial creíble para
los países en delante américa latina
y hablábamos recientemente con nuestra
corresponsal en londres con luisa kuliok
acerca de estos aires independentistas
que sobrevuelan por la región como un
lograra estábamos hablando de los casos
de las landas de escocia como cree usted
que podría lograr reino unido- mantener
no cierta cuestión mantenerse
cuestionado en medio de este contexto
y esta es una buena pregunta también si
como quiere digo es curioso porque por
gestión son y los conservadores
británicos se van en contra se van a
enfrentar al mismo fenómeno que tuvieron
con el que tuvieron que luchar más bien
del que beneficie beneficiarán ellos
cuando cuando hice una campaña a favor
del break shit
es decir que de nuevo pues hay unas
estrategias políticas básicas que es el
miedo el miedo que se puede usar el
miedo al vacío el miedo a lo desconocido
ese mismo miedo a lo desconocido que se
trataba de utilizar para impedir el
break city para que los británicos
votaran a favor de la del remake
puede pasar exactamente lo mismo con un
agravante o de pronto una un aspecto
favorable para los conservadores
británicos sí y para la cohesión de la
de la unión
y es que imagínense si ya de por si el
47 años de vida común
que ya nosotros seres humanos a escala
personal podemos imaginar más o menos a
nuestra tenemos abuelos que se han que
han tenido 50 años de matrimonio o
incluso papás que de pronto tiene 30
años de matrimonio y tienen miedo a lo
que puede venir después del divorcio
imagínense en el caso de escocia irlanda
en el que el matrimonio no duró 89 50
años sino que duró 800 años estamos ante
una situación un poco particular y yo
creo que los el ser humano ha demostrado
ser un ser es el ser un ser de
costumbres a luchar de hábitos y en este
caso específico la razón de la misma
manera que no sé que quebec o en
cataluña las votaciones o las opiniones
están en desfavor de la de la
independencia en la realidad a pesar de
que los independentistas tomen más
espacio público lo mismo pasará en
escocia irlanda es muy poco probable que
realmente vayan a arriesgarse porque el
salto al disco del salto al vacío es aún
mayor que lo que pasó con el break si el
caso irlandés de pronto es un poco más
complicado porque como dije antes
en la irlanda del norte se queda en la
unión europea en este momento y por eso
son son logro logro el desafío logro el
reto también creíble de poner en disco
en su contra tanto los que
tradicionalmente están en contra de
westminster que son los independiza
solos o los digamos republicanos
irlandeses pero también a los
conservadores que se sienten
traicionados por el dax top o sea la
política digamos de de mantenimiento de
la de irlanda en la en la comunidad
económica europea entonces es en ese
caso de pronto políticamente podría
beneficiarse de circunstancias
particulares para un para reunificar las
dos cosas pero es que las posiciones en
irlanda son tan polarizadas entre los
dos para protestantes y católicos que no
veo muy fácil que esos que eso ocurra
estamos acercándonos al final de este
programa especial de france 24
dedicado al break city que ya se hizo
oficial a partir de hoy nivel amarillo
volvemos contigo en cualquier momento
para conocer sus conclusiones acerca de
este tema y regresamos nuevamente a la
capital británica a londres para
dialogar otra vez con luisa pulido
corresponsal de france 24 luisa como
decía recién ya estamos llegando al
final de este programa especial y vamos
a avanzar ahora con las conclusiones que
nos esperan mejor dicho que les espera a
los británicos y a los europeos de ahora
en más que podemos esperar
y también estamos llegando a los últimos
minutos de este 2020 tan retador aquí en
el reino unido- por supuesto es un
acuerdo que apenas empezará a
implementarse a partir de 10 minutos
empezará entonces en la nueva relación
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
habrá mucho que implementar mucho por
hacer mucho por leer
leer con lupa todo el acuerdo leer la
ley del break sí que habrá que
implementar muchas transformaciones
muchos cambios como el primer ministro
podrá entonces honrar su promesa de que
el break sheet será lo mejor para la
economía quiero decirles una cifra bien
interesante de santiago televidentes un
centro de pensamiento muy prestigioso
aquí que se llama kate engine change in
europe dice que este acuerdo comercial
puede bajar el crecimiento económico del
reino unido un 6.4 por ciento y que
sería incluso una catástrofe peor que la
pandemia del coronavirus así que los
retos para el primer ministro son por
supuesto en mantener la economía en
flote se habla del reino unido es la
quinta economía del mundo muy poderosa
mantenerla a flote en medio de esta
situación con el break sheet pero lo
cierto es que también hay que empezar a
negociar lo importante ya se negoció el
urgente hay que negociar entonces los
servicios financieros los datos
y esto debe hacerse dentro de los
siguientes tres meses
luisa pulido a muchísimas gracias por
haber estado acompañándonos con esta
importantísima cobertura desde londres
la capital británica te agradecemos
muchísimo su excelente cobertura como
siempre y ahora volvemos con nicolás
mauricio docente de relaciones
internacionales nicolás no quedan apenas
unos pocos más de tres minutos de este
programa especial dedicado al break sit
pero te quería consultar en este tramo
final tus conclusiones que podemos
esperar de ahora es más la misma
pregunta que le hacía nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis ha pulido
bueno pues yo creo que para sintetizar
rápidamente la situación para gran
bretaña actualmente es probablemente más
problemática que la de la unión europea
la unión europea que acaba incluso de
firmar un acuerdo con nada con la
república república popular de china
para aumentar las inversiones europeas
en su territorio y facilitar el comercio
en incluso un acuerdo político con ellos
yo creo que el problema que tiene gran
bretaña actualmente es que no ha logrado
lo que se aprobó se ha propuesto en este
instante el reto es inmenso porque por
un lado perdieron su área su aliado
principal en contra ya que perdió las
elecciones y esto pues con bailén más
eurófilo y pues probablemente pierde la
posibilidad de un acuerdo gigante
los países del commonwealth no todos
están es muy animados muy motivados para
volver a una relación muy más íntima con
su con su madre patria entre comillas
incluso hay países como canadá que están
replanteando la idea de formar parte del
reino unido- entonces el reto es enorme
y hasta el momento en los últimos años
desde el éxito sólo han podido firmar un
acuerdo de comercial con japón que está
casi con los mismos términos que los que
tenían la unión europea entonces
está global breaking de la que hablaba
digamos boris johnson no está hecha para
nada y efectivamente sin los servicios
de acceso de los servicios financieros
al mercado único europeo gran bretaña
pierde en un billón de dólares creo de
cifra de negocio anual no estoy
completamente seguro pero que sí estoy
seguro es que el reto hoy en día es
mucho más grande para el reino unido que
para la unión europea que obtuvo más o
menos lo que quería este acuerdo ni
coraza ahora sí nos queda un poco más de
un minuto pero no quiero dejar de hacer
de esta pregunta que tiene que ver con
lo que estaban diciendo recientemente no
estos de los retos de los puntos que
quedan todavía por negociar cuál
considera que es el más clave el más
importante
para gran bretaña es el financiero
claramente para para gran bretaña es el
financiero para la unión europea de
pronto son los mecanismos reales de
sanciones que se podrán implementar en
caso de faltas de gran bretaña a la
competencia la leal competencia en el
caso del dumping financiero en caso de
tantín fiscal de gran bretaña e la unión
europea necesita de tener herramientas y
creo que estos mecanismos en la
negociación estos mecanismos es lo más
importante para europa pero para gran
bretaña son los mecanismos financieros
claramente
nicolás mauricio docente de relaciones
internacionales muchísimas gracias por
haber participado de este programa de
france 24 agradecemos también a nuestra
corresponsal en londres louis a pulido
por habernos acompañado y ayuda a
comprender más esta cobertura sobre esta
jornada histórica que se vive en reino
unido y en europa con el break city que
finalmente se hizo oficial agradecemos a
nuestra audiencia por acompañarnos es
todo por el momento regresamos en breve
con más noticias sigan informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y por
supuesto como le decimos siempre en
nuestra página web www puntos france24
puntocom
[Música]